you guys raise a lot of money why do you
need so much money we we're kind of
going for it all here like we're not
just going for yields right now
businesses can sign up with us and earn
up to four percent potential yields we
have a conservative yield offering we
always have
but phase two the company is why we
raise the money that's not the end all
deal we're going for the entire
corporate finance stack and we think it
can fundamentally be done better when
built on
crypto rails but without making that
clear to the end user okay what is
corporate finance for those that don't
know like explain is that just like
counting hey how much revenue we have
what our expenses are or what is that
yeah specifically things like invoicing
things like treasury management things
like spend ultimately uh forex is a big
one but these are like the practical use
cases of crypto not the cosmic brain
things like anyone could pitch anything
in 2021 and get funding correct
we come from the ground floor of an
exchange so we know what actually like
people need and that's kind of what
we're going for and that's what the
money's gonna be used for so people uh
so far uh until recently they come to
meow which i'm saying it correctly right
uh is um uh and they look for treasury
management like yield generation meaning
that rather than have cash sit in the
bank at whatever bank and earn 0.03 i
think is the average uh in a in a
deposit account uh they can come to you
and earn up to four percent yeah where
does that yield come from yeah so that's
a great question so how we've done
things differently from day one and this
is back when we started in april of last
year 2021. we made it so that the
customers actually had to pick exactly
where their funds went so it's not like
a black box you give the money and it
says all right we'll give you an
interest rate they have to pick do they
want it to go to an institutional
lending desk like genesis so they wanted
to go to this desk do they want it to go
to a d5 protocol
their money goes exactly where they want
it to and we also only face accredited
investors so we don't face retail
so those are the two two differences for
us but it was mostly
it is mostly institutional lending desks
that traditionally lend to crypto hedge
funds et cetera so when i run a business
let's say i'm the cfo at some large
corporation i'm staring at you know tens
of millions of dollars sitting on our
balance sheet uh i'm like damn we're
getting crushed with inflation i want to
earn a little bit more yield uh i come
to the platform and i'm able to pick who
the counterparty is in the sense of the
actual lending desk uh and there's a
yield that is associated with that um
what kind of diligence can i do or like
how do i decide right if there's ten
different options or five different
options like how do i as just a regular
cfo doesn't know that much about crypto
know who to go with yeah so it's kind of
painful for us but we have to write like
30 pages of like the risk profile of
everything and explaining exactly what
could go wrong with everything and we
get on calls with all of our customers
and we make sure they understand the
risks fully uh we send them documents we
send agreements and when they are
accredited and when they understand the
risk profile of these offerings uh they
pick what makes sense for them some
corporates like to do pretty aggressive
high-yield stuff you know ranging in
like six seven percent now we never
dabbled in the 20 stuff that a lot of
the retail apps did that just didn't add
up to us like that was sketchy from day
one to us but we hit we definitely
curate uh to some extent but it's
ultimately up to the investor so four
percent sounds a lot closer to uh what
you'd see in the traditional world than
there was people running around offering
10 11 12 13 crazy numbers uh
why did those high numbers sound so
risky and and what is your analysis as
to what people were doing there uh that
you guys don't do yeah it's a great
question so
unfortunately retail only competes on
one vector so retail yield apps for
example it's the rate and retail
investors tend to be uninformed and
that's why they go after the highest
rate possible and so one retail app
would be offering 10 and then the next
one would try to one-up them and say we
offered 12. and that would keep going
and going and going and the only way to
do that in the crypto world was through
the anchor protocol that was ust
so pretty much all these retail apps or
the vast majority of them
were taking people's cash
converting it to ust putting it into the
anchor protocol which as you know usd
blew up and giving a
dollar liability to their end users
so even though the interest in the
anchor protocol went back to the asset
that was ust
the yield app was saying we're gonna pay
you in dollars so that was where the
mismatch came and when usd lost its peg
and it went to zero that's why they lost
a lot of money so those were the
incentives for retail corporates is a
totally different story they care about
being conservative they care about like
you know risk reward they care about
understanding the risk profiles but
that's why retail apps got in a lot of
trouble uh this time around now not all
of them but most of them most of them
yeah